[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
we have an important and very unique
oversight role when it comes to
any issue affecting the liberties and
freedoms of all texans a victory for
those fighting to change the death
penalty sentence for a woman in texas
convicted of murder and we are live in
fairfax county virginia at some point
was mr depp's fingertip found
yes
who found it
i did jurors hear testimony about the
aftermath of johnny depp's finger being
severed in australia plus the results of
ms herd's evaluation supported two
diagnoses borderline personality
disorder and histrionic personality
disorder a forensic psychologist tells
the jury she believes amber heard
suffers from personality disorders but
first see what the jury and judge think
tell the world johnny tell them johnny
depp i signed up man
johnny depp wraps up his testimony on
redirect in the multi-million dollar
defamation case against ex-wife amber
heard law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer johnny
depp's attorneys finish out the actor's
testimony strong with a jury hearing an
audio recording of an intense argument
between him and ex-wife amber heard as
the multi-million dollar defamation
trial continues in virginia
law and crimes anjanet levy is on the
ground in fairfax virginia and has been
in the courtroom for much of today's
testimony anjanet
well brian another busy day here at the
fairfax county courthouse johnny depp as
you mentioned he recall he testified for
more than three days answering questions
about text messages audio recordings and
his substance abuse issues the
cross-examination was tough but on
redirect depp's attorney jessica myers
asked him questions about an audio
recording between him and amber heard in
2016 after she had filed for divorce and
obtained a domestic violence restraining
order and they discussed the allegations
of abuse that herd made
it's been going on too long
and we just got to stop this
it's gonna stop
i don't know how to get my
reputation back
[Music]
we write a letter together
saying that we're going to take this out
of the public eye
that we love each other
and that we want to make sure each other
is okay
have we had fights in the past that we
had this or whatever
they already know
don't matter
here's the deal no it matters
i have been i
that
you have no idea every ounce of my
credibility
has been taken from i mean and gunstone
is dishonest right
you know
[Music]
the abuse the abuse thing is is is we've
got to deal with that yeah
by going on the offense i didn't force
you
i promise
see what the jury and judge think tell
the world johnny tell them johnny depp i
joined up man i'm i'm a victim too with
jonathan
and when asked after that audio
recording stopped playing johnny depp
said when asked by his attorney jessica
myers oh what he said at the end he said
yes i am i am a victim of domestic
violence and that's how the redirect
ended there was no recross it was a very
powerful way to end his testimony brian
indeed and jeanette that last audio
recording that we just heard played
during depth redirect do you think it
gave greater context to herd's other
recordings
i think it did and there were a number
of other recordings played on
cross-examination
ben rottenborn played short snippets of
some of these audio recordings that
frankly made johnny depp look incredibly
bad then there were longer portions of
those same audio recordings played on
redirect and i think it gave you and he
then he answered questions about them
what was going on at the time and while
there may have been vulgar language
involved and things like that i think it
added uh some information to what may
have been going on at the time that
those conversations were recorded yeah
and angie you kind of touched on it here
that uh some of the information in the
redirect kind of clarified the
cross-examination but do you think it
fully explained away any issues brought
up by rottenborn and herds attorneys
you know i really think that um jessica
myers did a really good job of
methodically going through things that
they felt were the major points that
needed to be clarified she didn't overdo
it she didn't really get like going into
extraneous stuff that may not be that
important that could be addressed
through other witnesses she stuck to
what she felt needed to be addressed or
what the team felt needed to be
addressed
and she went through it very
methodically and very calmly so i
thought she did a nice job
now the jury has kind of heard amber
heard through some of the recordings but
she hasn't testified as yet so before
she gets to the stand what do you think
her credibility is at this point
well it's hard to tell you know it's all
we we haven't heard her side of the
story we are in johnny depp's case we
are here listening to his case in chief
so we haven't heard from her and it's
hard to tell what the jury might think
she could get up there and say things
and if they formed an opinion about her
they could change their minds
but she's not looking very good right
now in many respects um especially on
some of these recordings yeah it seems
like an uphill battle at this point but
we'll see how that continues and stay
with us angela we'll be right back still
ahead on law and crime daily our
coverage of the johnny depp versus amber
heard defamation trial continues coming
up a forensic psychologist hired to
evaluate amber heard testifies telling
the jury of her diagnosis of her having
personality disorders
[Music]
welcome back more now on the
multi-million dollar defamation case
between ex-spouses johnny depp and amber
heard on tuesday dr shannon curry took
the stand she's a forensic psychologist
hired by depp's legal team she told
jurors heard suffers from personality
disorders
the results of ms herd's evaluation
supported two diagnoses
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder one of
the hallmark characteristics of
histrionic borderline or sorry
histrionic personality disorder is sort
of a
overly dramatic presentation we call
this impressionistic speech it really
lacks
any substance so at the end you're left
wondering what was just said or what the
answer is to the actual question so that
occurred a number of times um and it
also represented the kind of the quick
shifts you'll see between emotions so
she would suddenly be one way and then
she would become very animated
or
very
sad and when people are displaying these
emotions with this personality disorder
there's a sense of shallowness to it
they don't really refer to i feel this
way they might describe emotions they
might describe events but very rarely
and i misheard did not say i feel
vulnerable she never really indicated a
vulnerable feeling of her own
is legal analyst matt mangino co-host
terry austin and lawn crime
correspondent angenette leady matt
heard's attorneys all but walked her off
the plank when they tried to argue her
experts had contrary opinions to dr
curry but on redirect we found out they
all have to take her for her word and dr
curry doesn't so is that bad for herd's
case
well i think what's important here is
that dr curry um had an opportunity to
distinguish her testimony and her
expertise from these other experts uh
that amber herb's uh council was trying
to use to uh attack her credibility and
basically you know she
informed this jury that not only am i
looking at
what's been said but i'm also analyzing
what's been said and i'm also testing
what's been said so although i might
have different conclusions than these
other experts it's because i've looked
at it with a different lens in terms of
analyzing uh the statements that amber
heard
made during the interview yeah different
lens i think is a really good way of
putting it so terry you had some choice
words for herds lawyers uh who
cross-examined
dr curry what'd you think of that cross
choice words indeed and i think some of
the viewers also had choice words elaine
bredehoff is unnecessarily nasty
she argued with dr curry and dr curry
stood her ground i have to hand it to
her she would not let council put words
in her mouth she stood by her diagnosis
she said that there was borderline
personality disorder she said that there
was histrionic personality disorder
there was not a diagnosis of ptsd and
basically she said look i'm not talking
about domestic violence because i'm not
qualified to assess crimes
very excellent witness stood up on cross
very well yeah now anjanet this case is
becoming a bit of a battle of the
experts did you get a sense for who the
jury believed more
you know it's going to be uh we're just
going to have to wait and see brian you
know dr curry you know she did seem to
stand her ground and she distinguished
between her testing and analyzing amber
heard with these various tests
she said there's a difference between me
doing this and treatment providers who
meet with somebody and provide medical
care for them so they don't typically i
guess do testing she said so
it may be a battle of the experts i am
sure we will hear from experts uh over
on amber heard's side but it's going to
probably end up being who the jury
believes deaf or heard absolutely temper
heard is a major question here and thank
you for the great reporting as always uh
look forward to see you soon
next on law and crime daily a closer
look into the allegedly abusive
relationship of johnny depp and amber
hurt coming up the jury hears a
first-hand account of the damage left
behind in an australian home after the
ex-spouse's argument
[Music]
welcome back as we continue our coverage
of actor versus am actress in johnny
depp's defamation trial against ex-wife
amber hurd in virginia after testimony
from debt wrapped on monday ben king
took the stand he was the property
manager at a home in australia where
depp hurt and heard stayed in 2016. he
testified about finding depp's fingertip
and the damage he discovered in the
house after an argument between the
ex-spouses
so i spoke to david kipper
who was in the kitchen area
seemingly rummaging through a bin
he said he was that mr depp had
sustained an injury to his finger one of
his fingers and he was looking for
the fingertip that that it said it had
been severed at some point was mr depp's
fingertip found
yes
who found it
i did there's a bit of damage down the
steps that big chunk had been taken out
of the marble staircase um on my way
down with remnants of what looked like a
plant pot or something around it smashed
walking down into the bar i could see
the damage that
dr kippur told me about
a broken ping pong table sort of
collapsed onto the floor and lots of
glass and broken glass on the floor
around the area the puddles of what
smelled like alcohol to me there were
seemed like several drinking glasses a
couple of bottles one was a stolikniya
vodka bottle at the end of the bar on
the as i said there was a big chunk out
of the bar itself the marble top whose
job was it to clean all that up
that was mine
it was mine
terry herr's attorneys seemed like laser
focused on destroyed paintings that
seemed odd to me at points uh why do you
think they did that
well i think herd's attorney was trying
to focus on all of the damaged property
to kind of show that johnny depp is a
violent person but that's really besides
the point we know that he can be violent
against property in fact he has said
he's beaten up a cabinet or two
he also was very focused on the photos
that ben king took and i thought that
was unusual he kept asking well how many
photos did you take who asked you for
those photos did you produce all of the
photos and at one point ben king even
said do you want to look at the rest of
them so i don't think it was important
that the paintings were destroyed and i
also don't think it was that important
how many photos were produced the fact
is there are lots of photos and you can
see them all yeah now matt do you think
king's testimony of the damage at the
bar i'm thinking specifically that like
little chip on the countertop that you
think that confirms that herd caused
depth to lose a piece of his finger
well i i think what this witness does is
really set the scene uh for what is
obviously a
violent episode between the two of them
uh you know whether the rage was
physical in terms of how um you know
each of them responded to one another
certainly
he sets the scene and johnny depp can
tell the story and that's what's
happened here johnny depp has explained
how he lost his fingertip
this guy helps to set the scene for what
it was like that that evening
all right we'll continue with more
johnny depp another day thank you both
for contributing an execution put on
pause when we come back the story of
melissa lucille and how advocates worked
alongside texas state legislators to
halt her execution
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
jurors here at the video deposition of a
surviving victim of an alleged serial
killer in court as defendant billy
shamirmir faces a retrial on murder
charges in texas though shamirmir is
only on trial for one count of murder
he's accused of killing at least 18
elderly women in the dallas and plano
areas of texas between 2016 and 2018.
police believe he will would pose as a
maintenance worker to gain access to
homes and senior living communities
prosecutors say the victim lou harris
was smothered to death by a pillow in
her plano home in 2018.
they say authorities found several items
belonging to harris when shamirmir was
arrested for a separate alleged attack
police made the connection between
shamir mir and harris after mary bartel
was attacked by a man at her home and
survived bartel passed away in 2020 but
not before police were able to interview
her about her attacker on video
he was inside and in my apartment
and he said
don't fight me
lie on the bed
so i did as he said because i knew
i could not overpower him physically
and of course as soon as i um
lay down on the bed
he could lie down on the bed anyway um
he just smashed
a
pillow down hard over
my
my face and my chest
and i i just couldn't breathe after
i don't know three minutes or however
long it seemed longer than that of
course
that he was
just using all his weight to
keep me from
from breathing at all
i passed out
also in texas the court of criminal
appeals granted a stay of execution for
melissa lucille monday just days before
her scheduled execution lucille's family
attorneys and other advocates say the
mother of 14 was wrongly convicted of
capital murder in 2000 in the 2007 death
of her two-year-old daughter mariah
several jurors have even said they made
the wrong decision in sentencing lucille
to death lucille's defense attorneys
argue she was wrongly convicted on the
basis of a coerced confession after an
hours-long interrogation the night of
her daughter's death despite this day
lucille will stay on death row while her
case is examined two weeks ago before
the court's decision lucille's case was
discussed at a hearing for the texas
house criminal justice reform committee
led by texas state representative jeff
leach the man who ultimately delivered
the news of the stay to lucille
we have an important and very unique
oversight role when it comes to
any issue affecting the liberties and
freedoms of all texans
in this case one
texan specifically in melissa lucio when
those freedoms and liberties
are on the line representative moody and
i vice chair moody
and a few other legislators who aren't
here today
went and
to gatesville texas last week and
visited miss lucio on death row we
promised miss lucio as we hugged her
neck and held her hand and prayed with
her vice chair moody and the other
legislators members and i promised her
that we would do everything we can
to push the pause button
at the very least just to push the pause
button
because in two weeks on april 27th
the life of a fellow texan um is on the
line
matt so how much and how strong does
this new evidence have to be to get
lucille a new trial
well brian you know i i've studied and
written about the death penalty
extensively in fact my book the
executioner's toll
examines the death penalty in the 21st
century
and it's not really not um surprising to
see a reprieve like this uh you know on
the eve
of execution what um
lucio is his uh suggested is that there
is uh actual innocence she did not
commit this crime and there's new
scientific evidence and that there was
some false testimony uh that was
presented in her case now this is a
collateral attack
of a conviction after uh the direct
appeals have been exhausted so um this
is not the end this is merely maybe the
beginning of the end
of this case uh for um
melissa lucia yeah now tara when we take
all that evidence that matt gave us uh
based on it and and the coming out of
these jurors pushing for a new trial do
you think if they get a new trial that
the prosecution would just dismiss the
case altogether
you know what it's possible brian but i
think the prosecution will probably try
to retry the case the fact is the trial
court has to hold all of these hearings
to determine which way to go they're
going to make a recommendation to the
texas court of appeals and they're
looking at this new evidence they're
looking at whether or not the medical
examiner actually ignored that death
could have had other causes other than
murder they're looking at whether or not
it was a false confession they're
looking at scientific evidence to show
whether or not the child was actually
murdered and whether or not the
prosecutors suppress evidence so i think
those are very important questions and
we'll see what happens
absolutely well matthew terry thank you
very much and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you